actually you know the Vibes be outside
every day all the way from New York to
Cali you already know the Bronx is in
the building boss is here we everywhere
yeah it's crazy uh you've never been on
my show though no never really yeah no
you never been on my [ __ ] we we did the
above all [ __ ] we hung out in New York
we did Corner Store brunch make a wish
uh oh 11 11. you know what's great about
that that's the name of my nightclub
what I'm having a little crazy y'all
left work see how that work damn it uh
all right you got a new album coming
that's a fact we drop February yeah
February 10th I'm gonna live for me 2023
Vibes new energy okay new music so we're
just giving them a new type of vibe yeah
what's the name it's gonna be called
It's My Tom because I feel like right
now it's definitely my time like after
everything I work for me and the team
like we like 23 2023 that's it for
greatness I ain't gonna lie yeah you had
a busy 2022 too obviously you guys put
the group project out yeah with you on
point like op Dusty Rosswell
um you were you were the only guy not
from Brooklyn on that huh no most
definitely yeah
and I feel like probably the only person
I ever did a table Brooklyn people yeah
in New York like that if I mean
especially like speaking from the Bronx
it's Bridging the Gap right yeah so I
was probably the only person to do that
I know in a minute make a tape of
Brooklyn people and like I feel like if
you're not in New York to win for me
have you been able to uh chop it up with
Dusty since he's been locked up I mean I
still send my love ownership but for me
I I didn't really get to speak to him in
Europe yeah when the Thomas ride
definitely going to speak I mean I think
he knew he was going in so yeah he gonna
be out real soon
he gonna be real soon we're gonna turn
this [ __ ] up again you know she never
stop yeah 100 man